going into this obviously this is a much
different process for you guys with
without Mike what was that like the sort
of day one when you sat down and you
were you were like okay we're working on
a new album I mean he was involved in he
knew but a lot of the songs we did yeah
play it on some of the on the record so
he's okay yeah so it's it's it's really
cool that we can put these songs out
because he was he was a part of it but
yeah it was it was definitely a
different process and finishing the
album you know not having him there and
this it was tough but I know he was
proud he was proud of a lot a lot of the
songs and he knew that there's some of
some of our best work
[Music]
with mics on you guys did some
incredible work with kids and music was
that always there gonna be the point to
sort of make this more than a song yeah
sort of do a lot of good with it I think
there's like 25 kids there's a bunch of
kids that we couldn't fit everything in
the video yeah he was always trying to
do what he could to get instrument in
the hands of kids that you know
otherwise couldn't get their hands on
them you know so as soon as you know we
started working on that project we
reached out to through the Junos and and
their charity music counts and just said
how can we make this can you guys help
us make this project the way Mike would
want
dials
as far as what is a first single and
what do you want people to hear first is
that decision all up to you and how do
you make that decision it's actually
really great nowadays because people
release singles all the time so there
isn't so much pressure to like make sure
that it is the one the one that you
release you know that's gonna kind of
drive the whole album but our single
right now is I'll be there and that song
you know was a following Mike song was
really kind of the transition that we
went to from being a tragic sad
something that you really need to
overcome to recognizing the people
around you the people that support you
the people that love you and having that
be a really positive message when songs
like that are so personal and you
initially start to hear the reaction
from fans is there a sigh of relief that
you guys sort of made the right decision
to put all of that in a song yeah yeah
they get it yeah
[Music]